la question des écoles est une question
à la fois sensible qui interroge
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
les professeurs les parents d'élèves
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui se
demandent comment est ce que les écoles
vont pouvoir ouvrir le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a passé toute la
semaine à discuter avec les
organisations syndicales qui
représentent les professeurs celle qui
représente les chefs d'établissements
les fédérations de parents d'élèves les
associations d'élus qui évidemment des
responsabilités éminentes en matière
d'éducation les maires pour les écoles
de maternelle et primaire
les département pour les collèges les
régions pour les lycées et l'objectif
c'est de trouver la bonne méthode
à l'évidence je veux le dire cette bonne
méthode sera progressif
les écoles n'ouvriront pas partout le 11
mai et ne fonctionnera pas partout le 11
mai dans les conditions dans lesquelles
elle fonctionnait le 11 février ou le 11
janvier où avant les mesures de
confinement mais nous devons commencer à
ouvrir les écoles pour une raison très
simple qui tient à l'impératif de
continuité de la vie de la nation que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
beaucoup de professeurs font un travail
remarquable pour accompagner les élèves
alors même que nous sommes en période de
confinement il travaille de chez eux
utilisent les nouvelles technologies
il donne du travail parfois ils font des
cours qui sont diffusés par internet
il donne des consignes il corrige bref
ils font en sorte que le lien entre
l'élève et le professeur qui évidemment
d'une nature très différente en perdre
de confinement et parfois d'une nature
un peu insatisfaisante soit maintenu que
le travail d'acquisition de réflexion
vous allez dire d'élévation même des
élèves puissent se poursuivre mais un
certain nombre d'élèves n'ont pas accès
à ces instruments un certain nombre
d'élèves soit pour des raisons liée à
l'inégalité territoriale
l'inégalité sociale
on se retrouve dans une situation où le
lien avec l'école est rompu
et ce n'est pas un petit nombre d'élèves
c'est une proportion de l'ordre de 5 à
10% nous disent les professeurs les
professeurs eux-mêmes mais qui
évidemment peut être beaucoup plus
importante dans certains territoires ou
dans certains quartiers qui se trouvent
privés de tout contact avec l'école
cette situation est une situation qui
présente pour la nation un grave danger
et nous devons donc faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des enfants
bien entendu mais singulièrement ceux
qui voient le lien avec l'école se
distendre le plus puissent reprendre le
chemin de l'école comme l'a indiqué le
président de la république il faut
qu'ils puissent le faire dans des
conditions de sécurité sanitaire
respectez bien entendu les enfants
c'est ce que nous disent les
scientifiques ne craignent ne semble je
vais utiliser des termes prudents ne
semble rien craindre pour eux mêmes car
l'immense majorité quasi exclusivité des
enfants sont atteints par des formes
bénignes voix totalement asymptomatiques
de la maladie mais ils peuvent
transmettre le virus
il faut donc garantir les gestes
barrière dans l'école et c'est
évidemment difficile il faut évidemment
éviter que le circulent ne le pardon que
le virus ne puisse remettre à circuler à
cause du rassemblement des enfants
il faudra donc mettre en place des
mesures progressives j'ai demandé au
ministre de l'éducation nationale nous
avons demandé ensemble à ce que des
scénarii des hypothèses soit travailler
avec nos partenaires pour voir lesquels
seraient les plus susceptibles de nous
permettre de ré ouvrir progressivement
les écoles des scénarios différencier
par exemple selon les territoires
dans un certain nombre de territoires en
france dans certains départements il n'y
a eu quasiment aucun cas et on peut
évidemment considérer qu'après deux mois
de confinement
cette situation sera préservée et que
donc les territoires seront presque
exemple de virus ou en tout cas avec une
présence négligeable on peut imaginer
que dans ces territoires
l'ouverture se fasse plus rapidement
façon plus large que dans d'autres
territoires où la situation est plus
compliquée parce que le virus a plus
circuler où circulent encore un peu plus
je ne dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
je dis que nous devons nous poser la
question est étudiée localement la façon
dont il est possible de réouvrir les
écoles de la même façon nous pouvons
évidemment imaginer des hypothèses où ce
serait des moitiés de classe qui
rentrerait à partir du 11 mai et qui une
semaine sur deux pourrait avoir le lien
physique et intellectuel avec le
professeur pour ensuite alterné avec
l'autre moitié de la classe
on peut imaginer l'utilisation des
locaux de façon différente en utilisant
des espaces plus larges que de simples
classe pour faire court on peut imaginer
beaucoup de choses et nous devons
travailler sur toutes les hypothèses
nous devons travailler sur toutes ces
hypothèses avec les maires qu'un rôle
éminent nous devons travailler sur ces
hypothèses avec les professeurs qui
savent comment ils peuvent faire cours
comment ils souhaitent faire court nous
devons travailler ces hypothèses avec
l'ensemble des partenaires
c'est un fait un énorme travail de
préparation il a commencé je ne veux pas
faire état de décision à ce stade car
elles sont en train d'être travaillée je
souhaitais évoquer